[Music]
foreign
you've gone to another level how tough
is it to handle that actually you just
gotta
take it and be you remain yourself
keeping good people around me helps me
to stay grounded
[Applause]
[Music]
E.T first met an 18 year old Riri in
2006 when her first number one U.S hit
SOS dominated the charge at the time she
was still finishing High School you're
in school right yep it's a little
disappointing sometimes because you know
I'm used to having summer off especially
when it's at the end of my day and I
just want to chill right but it's okay
in 2007 Rihanna's next number one hit
the Jay-Z collab umbrella catapulted her
into a global Superstar your life is
good right now it couldn't be better
Rihanna featuring Jay-Z
the single earned Rihanna her first of
nine Grammys I'd like to thank
Jay-Z for being a part of this record
with me she like to thank man for
being the greatest in the world
you just shush Jay-Z On Stage is that
what you did I see that he is silly oh
my gosh that was all good fun
[Applause]
[Music]
my biggest dream was become a singer you
know here I am living my dream with
sales of over 250 million records
worldwide Rihanna has become the second
best-selling female music artist of all
time
and she did it all while remaining
unapologetically authentic to herself
[Music]
I think a lot of it is honesty I think
not being afraid of the truth I guess
you don't come by it very oft and that's
what I'm really encouraging my fans to
do to live live like that that means
breaking out of your comfort zone to try
something new are you ready to play with
the big boys oh yes in 2010 E.T set sail
with Rihanna on set of her first big
film role in the Blockbuster battleship
what I was really excited about was
playing a part that is so unlike Rihanna
it's my first film and I don't want to
just
shoot for something that I can't achieve
I wanted it to be a role that I was
capable of perfecting and with an
estimated net worth of 1.4 billion
dollars Rihanna is also the wealthiest
female musician of all time
[Music]
riri's Empire includes her lucrative
fenny Lifestyle brand which launched in
2017. and now it's like sky's the limit
no rules all women deserve to feel
beautiful
the journey has been incredible it's a
lot of hard work but last year Rihanna
took on her proudest role mom when she
and long time love ASAP Rocky welcome
their first son
shine bright like a diamond
what is the best part about motherhood
right now again oh my God the mornings
just like seeing his morning face it's
the cutest is my favorite part of the
day but it has also been more than seven
years since this busy working mama has
dropped a studio album the Rihanna Navy
and E.T have been begging her to please
don't stop them
make the stage in your life is going to
inspire new music oh gosh yes you're
still gonna get music from me a lullaby
oh my goodness not a lullaby my fans
would kill me they waited this long for
a lullaby please don't stop the music
[Music]